he's uh russell wilson jr the third beat
the falcons
in atlanta he uh threw for four
touchdowns
they host the patriots coming up sunday
night he just uh debuted his new podcast
called danger talk and we'll uh
talk about that coming up what did you
watch on tv last night at home
oh what's up dad first of all um you
know i i watched the game last night it
was
it was actually a great game to watch
you know anytime football's back it's a
good thing so
uh it was definitely a good game but how
do you watch a game
i i i analyze everything okay i'm like
back there playing quarterback i'm
making
you know i'm making the moves at the
same time i'm also a fan you know so
when certain guys make great catches i'm
sharing as loud as i can
so i i'm you know i'm a problem when i'm
watching a game did you hear what
belichick had to say about you
i didn't hear exactly what he said but
let me play it because
i man this is a love letter to you russ
here's uh here's coach belichick
this guy's a tremendous player honestly
i think
he's you know in a way maybe underrated
by by the media or the fans i don't know
but i mean i don't really see anybody
better than this player
he can do everything he's got obviously
great leadership
play-making skills he plays very well in
the most critical situations in the game
with his decision making
you put him up against anybody since
he's been in the league literally
anybody
or in any category really he never said
that about tom brady russ
yeah listen i i think he's trying to i
think he's trying to warm you up
i know it definitely to hear something
like that from coach belichick he's one
of the
you know if he's the best coach arguably
to ever coach the game you know with all
these championships he's won and
over the past 20 years and what he's
done and you know i i'm interested in
this game not just because of cam and i
but uh
more so between the two oldest coaches
and pete carroll 69 and
coach belichick being 68 but both both
of those guys have so much wisdom and
understanding of the game you know i
think i think more than anything else
though um
you know for me it's about my teammates
about what they get to do
and how they get to play and they make
me look better than i am i guess i don't
know but
you know for me every day i wake up i i
i wake up to try to be the best in the
world you know it's it's
it's in my head every day to try to
create a legacy that people can remember
and uh and try to be you know one of the
greatest if not the greatest quarterback
to ever play this game
do you think you're the best quarterback
in the nfl do i think i'm the best
quarterback in the nfl
i i i believe so okay without a doubt i
think but there's some great ones for
sure i think that uh
you guys like patrick holmes you got
guys obviously like lamar who had such a
great year last year
desean watson and then you got guys like
obviously the guys who've been so great
for so many years and
and tom and drew and uh you know aaron
those kind of players so
you know for me i'm just grateful to be
you know getting to play this game
you know one of 32 men in the world um
you know and and uh to have this
opportunity i think also at the same
time
you know with everything that's happened
this offseason with kovit
and and and all the things going on in
america you know honestly dan just to be
able to play this game and
get out in the field you know we played
with nobody in the stands the other day
and i felt like i was
i was playing minor league baseball
again all over again but uh
but it was uh it was a good time for
sure and of course facing the patriots
you know those super bowl questions
are going to come back have they come
back this week about when seattle played
new england in the super bowl no they
haven't come back and we've played them
we played them at in 2016 we played um
them and frat fox for a great matchup
great game
uh you know we got the media had asked
me about that game too as well and just
how
that was one of the best games they've
seen so we've always had some great
matches i go back to 2012 too
and my rookie year and i think that's
when uh i really you know
knew that you know i knew that i could
play but i think people started
realizing okay this could be this could
be interesting here in seattle so
i think it's been a blessing you know
like i said just to you know get back
out there and play ball again but i also
think because you came in
people didn't know much about you in the
big ten or the acc
and then you had the defense that was
the star of those teams
i think that's where people took a while
to really discover you i think you
became an overnight sensation after
maybe five years
it just took a longer period of time
like even the super bowl i said you were
the best
player on the field in that super bowl
against the patriots
and then you won a super bowl too yeah i
know
i think for me uh you know i've had some
great teammates and great coaches and
some great people around me
i think to do anything great in life you
got to have support you got to have
great players around you
you know you got to have those superstar
players too as well and it's been
sort of been a great process you know
for me you know like i said it's
i love the process of it all and you
know my job you know
especially now you know being my ninth
year in the league is
to to to help guys like dk metcalf be
the best in the world of what he does to
help
continue to help tyler lockett you know
show up and just show out every time he
steps on the field it's amazing
that guys like greg olsen who are
tremendous teammates and
will dissley and such such great players
guys like chris carson i want him to
be the best running back in the league
and continue to do what he does so yeah
but speaking of the running game russ
yeah is this the year pete carroll lets
you throw the football
in the first three quarters as opposed
to the fourth quarter
well i i think we definitely uh i think
we definitely mix it up a little bit
more and you know
i think that we have such tremendous
talent on the edge you know when we
think about dk tyler
uh so many different guys that can make
plays so you know uh i i i keep knocking
on pete's door just uh
but do you get mad at him like have you
ever said coach
can you stop making me win games in the
fourth quarter
how about we try to win games in the
first second and third quarter
well i think i think we got a good stat
i think coach carol and i think we got a
good stat it's like we're 57-0 i'm
leading at half or
58-0 or something like that so i i keep
knocking on coach's door say hey
he's russell wilson he's got his game
coming up by the way we're going to
develop a t-shirt
in your in your honor let russ
cook hey listen i i think that uh
i heard i hear those are already being
made here in seattle i don't know
if if not if not dan i think that uh
i think i think you gotta i think you
got a business on your hands
all right we'll send some for the family
you started this podcast danger
talk and uh you're doing it with
comedian jeff dye
so you're going to interview people
across sports entertainment business
worlds
the first two are shaq and then john
david washington the great actor
um what what made you say let's start a
podcast
well you know i i think for me it's
sitting here around
everything that's been going on it's
been really important for me to
to start talking about not just
obviously the sports entertainment but
also life and
how people have grown up and their
experiences and everything else and i
i'm obsessed with why people are
successful and understanding
you know that process so so for me
having you know shaq on
you know we had so much fun had a blast
talking about it is mount rushmore you
know
players that he's played with and so
many different people and
and i think that also too you know his
relationship with kobe and
and uh you know if he could say one last
thing to kobe i think we also talked
about
you know as well with john david
washington his new movie tenant and
just how he grew up with uh you know his
mom and his dad both being very
successful at what they did obviously
denzel and everything else but also his
mom
was well known too and just how he used
his craft
to be able to tell his story and to tell
tell what he does and he wants to create
his own identity and how
he grows up as a as a you know celebrity
child and everything else but how do you
how do you use how do you create your
own identity without people saying oh
that's just denzel's son or
whatever maybe and he's been able to do
that from uh ballers all the way to
playing the nfl but also um coming from
morehouse college and being one of the
best running backs
out of there and then obviously now uh
being the star in this
new movie new movie tenant which is
pretty amazing
i'm taking sierra out to it uh tonight
is the plan so
you know i'm excited about that so
anyways it's been really cool on danger
talk we got a really cool guest next
week
uh we'll talk about later but um we're
excited about it
wait wait who is it who's next week
well i can't tell you yeah we haven't
announced it yet so
why not this is how you announce it so
you know this is
you know it's available on apple podcast
in conjunction with espn the espn app
and uh social channels on espn so
well we have this whole reveal thing and
so okay can you give me a hint how about
you give the dan ants and myself a hint
and let's see if we could come up with
it
i'll i'll give you i'll give you a
couple of hands okay all right here we
go
i'll give you a couple options here all
right and
so the first one uh he played basketball
he plays basketball uh they're currently
out of the uh
currently out of um the playoffs
right now okay really good player kind
of leads
a group of people uh but then
some some organizations and such chris
paul
chris paul could be it
we have some other people you're not
good at playing poker
did you need preseason games do a second
did you need preseason games
i mean you came out firing against the
falcons well you know i think for me
uh you know i i didn't really need them
because of you know this
past this past year i didn't play in the
preseasons and you know you played so
many games i played over
100 and you know 30 40 games
you know uh you know the nfl so far
played a bunch you know in college and
everything else so now you can't
understand the game i think
the reason why preseason games are
significant is for the younger guys you
know i feel
the younger guys i i think about myself
and if i came in third round pick 75th
pick overall but no preseason games
how would i have proven myself you know
and so i think i think those pre-season
games are important for the younger guys
for me
um it i like the feel of it so we've had
a couple mock games and coach set up
you know i love i love the process of
getting ready for the game going through
my checklist of what gets me ready and
and doing that so um but i didn't feel
like i needed him necessarily
who's the second best quarterback in the
nfc west
the second best quarterback in the nfc
west oh man
you're i'm not i'm not a judge of
quarterbacks wait wait wait this is what
happens when you do a podcast
you have to ask questions like this well
we'll have to talk about it on my show
again
i uh i'm gonna take kyler murray right
now
i i look he's pretty special man he's
he's he can move around he can sling it
he's got great players hopkins and
and larry fitzfits obviously how did
arizona get de'andre hopkins and seattle
didn't go
after jamal adams is wonderful russ
but if i said you couldn't now you're
not going to tell me but here's another
podcast question
if you could have had deandre hopkins
instead of jamal adams
who would you take russell wilson oh man
listen both of
i mean he goes hopkins they got him for
nothing
yeah i mean he's uh he's pretty special
player he's pretty good
you know he he's made some catches i've
been been around him with pro bowls and
stuff like that
he's made some unbelievable catches so
he loves the game and
he's got an amazing story too i've
gotten to know him pretty well and
him and his mom's story and everything
else so i have a tremendous
respect for who he is any more babies
are we uh
on hold now listen i i keep telling c
you know it
it's a good time to do it you know
there's no concerts coming up you know
no but uh right now you know when
harrison wilson is
over there big old hands he's ready to
play quarterback and
uh he's running the show already now did
you come up with the name win
or how did that work because you
wouldn't reveal that to us last time we
talked to you
about name of the baby good names you
guys came up with hawk wilson you guys
came a whole bunch of different yeah
uh you know i i'm almost reconsidering
the hawk name but
no uh win win was something that me and
sierra always wanted to name our
uh you know you know our son and stuff
like that so uh
when hawk wilson
that's a little too much oh that's too
much
that's a little overdone you know but uh
you know for me
you know also my dad's name was harrison
so we wanted to put harrison in there
somewhere
and my brother had three girls and so
you know just in case he reconsidered
having
another another child his name's
harrison wilson iv
my my my dad's was harrison wilson the
third so you know just in case harry
harry ended up wanting to have another
one you know who knows
uh my best to your wife and uh good luck
with the podcast there it's called
danger talk available each week on apple
podcast espn app and espn social
channels
and the first two guests are shaq and
john david washington
uh good luck against the patriots there
russ thanks dan it's always a pleasure
go hawks
go hawks of course